so you think there's a lot of enrichment  that can occur at the intersection of  sort of social activism and education I  hope so that's what we're hoping here  and one thing that I would like to see  is a interchanges between students here  and students there and so far that  hasn't nothing's happened but we have  talked with several schools here about  that possibility well thank you students  Beth Neville thank you so much thanks  right now I max the bond we all hope to  be so sparkly this has been philanthropy  in action as Beth Neville has  passionately stated we all have so much  to give inside of us to find that inner  calling to make the world a better place  now what are you going to do to change  the world